e
e e
good morning everyone the time being uh
9 past 10:00 we'll get going I hope you
all have had a good summer and um this
uh should be our last Ways and Means
meeting I know the last one I said it
was our last one but I had forgotten
about the interim study bills
so here we are to dispatch those
um so I'm going to what I'm going to do
to start with I'm going to open a work
session on all three um School related
bills the 56 HB 569 hb514 HB
1563 I just want to open a work session
on all three of those at once and kind
of discuss in general uh part of the
issue is the Supreme Court still has not
made it decision um I checked with the
um uh with the Attorney General's office
uh through Jennifer 4 and um we tried to
get is anyone here from the Attorney
General's
office or or
doj okay um they were not able to send
someone in but basically there's
virtually nothing new from the last time
we got an update we still don't have any
decisions so I kind of just want to um
just see where people are with these
things um because today um since we are
working on interim study bills we each
bill is going to be either um
recommended for future legislation or
not recommended for future legislation
and um
so let's start with that representative
PL yes I'm going to be a broken record
today because I think we should not
recommend all of them including the
three School ones and the reason for the
three School ones is because the court
hasn't acted and we'll have to I think
we should wait for the court to act and
then and then uh put legislation
together
accordingly
okay representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman uh I'd like to
take the opposite view on that
um yes we've put these in interim study
and we're still waiting two decisions
from the New Hampshire Supreme Court in
the Rand case in the conval case and we
probably uh won't have seen those
decisions when the legislative uh the
LSR window opens and closes in November
so it's worthwhile to talk for a few
minutes about what kind of Bill or bills
we would like to see before the
committee so that if and when this opens
up we have something to work with um I
think that
uh there's Merit in seeing something
along the lines of
both uh 1514 and
1563 1514 is representative beckford's
bill that is very simple and
straightforward because it restores the
language that had been repealed by the
legislature in
2011 so that those
municipalities that have so-called
excess swept would have to remit that to
the state going to the education trust
fund and would be available for
redistribution 1563 on the other hand uh
completely repeals swept and replaces it
with a different approach that's more
consistent with a major bill that the
education committee has in in interim
study David Luna's bill I believe was um
1583 will almost certainly uh be
reintroduced in in very similar format
education committee
is meeting on October 3rd they have
about uh 25 interim study bills that
includes David lunos and it also
includes another uh swep bill so we've
got this confusion we've talked about
before where uh essentially the same
subject matter is being handled in ways
and means and in education uh with some
inconsistent and some overlapping
approaches we're going to need to
discuss this next year we should have a
bill or two that give us some choices in
a foundation for discussion and I think
those two bills do a pretty good job of
it Mr chair yes representative
James I agree with representative
spillsbury I I believe that um the
subject matter that these bills address
is um
is going to
require um
legislation and and that's really what
we're talking about uh is this uh does
this issue that's addressed by this
particular Bill uh such that it warrants
future legislation it's not not saying
what the legislation will be um but it's
saying yeah there's something here that
uh based on what we know
is likely to require us to uh you know
roll up our sleeves and figure out
something and in this case we're
handicapped today uh by um the
uncertainty of the uh uh law as it
applies to swept and as it applies to
the whole school funding formula for
that matter um and
uh it we don't know when the Supreme
Court will finally issue a decision just
adding a little bit of detail to the
status right now
um the uh briefing period
for um the parties in this case and for
Miki for that matter um closes at the
end of this roughly the end of this
month maybe a day or two into October
I'm not sure of that and um and once
that is done the court will schedule
oral argument I'm sure they will take or
oral argument on this uh these cases the
two cases one one is directly swept and
the other is uh is the amount of the the
sufficiency of the adequacy costing
formula and Grant
formula um and uh you know they'll come
out with a decision when they come out
with it and then
uh one could say almost with certainty
uh that the legislature is going to have
to get involved um not for certain
because who knows uh but uh likely and
uh so these
bills all represent good faith efforts
to try to um take steps down that new
road and um we're on pause as to how to
deal with them I think we should uh not
say no no future legislation is needed
and the other option is say yes future
legislation is needed I favor this the
second option
representative
Southworth thank you I agree with the
previous two speakers um I think um
really we need to be planning ahead just
in case um a lot of the weight will fall
on this Committee in one way or another
depending on the decision so I think to
already start doing some creative
thinking and you know have some type of
plans going forward really is the best
choice thank you uh representative ORS
thank you Mr chair uh I agree with both
sides on this I also believe that until
the Supreme Court makes the decision
we're not really going
anywhere however I believe we should do
a Bottoms Up approach I mean this is
like so convoluted rip the Band-Aid off
and let's start the healing build it
from the bottom up and let's get it
right representative
Aly thank you just to add something
about the time schedule uh the last time
we had this problem on it was
1998 and the Supreme Court uh issued its
decision on I think it was three weeks
uh one week into
December and then uh we all arrived and
the finance committee had absorbed the
Ways and Means Committee which in some
ways worked better and in some ways
worked worse
um but on we um the Supreme Court
realizes is that if they say something
that is going to require
legislation they they should they knew
and they should know now that they will
have to make a decision uh in December
at the
latest so that we will have time to try
to deal with it
thank you represented
fellows thank you I I just want I I
absolutely agree that having a couple of
options readily available next year
because they've been filed this build is
is a good idea because we are going to
have to deal with this and I just wanted
to add for for my bill um
fif
1563 that um I did an extensive amount
of work with
Dr to add some Provisions that deal with
really um
detailed issues related to the
transition if you were to get rid of
swep how do you go from having it to get
to getting rid of it in terms of how the
municipalities will will send out their
tax bills and calculate their
anticipated semiannual or quarter
quarter annual bills so so um I'm
confident that that has addressed all
the technical issues so I think that
that um you know that will be an
improvement over what we looked at and
will be a good option to present have
available thank
you representative PL animating what I
stated is that this is total waste of
time because whether we recommend or not
recommend it does not bind a future
legislature either way so let the future
legislature decide what bills are needed
or not needed
needed anybody anybody else on this
topic okay seeing none I will close the
work session
on hb5 uh 569 hb514 and HP 1563
yeah okay now we'll go back to the
beginning of the
uh calendar here and uh I will open the
work session on
hb5 relative to the rate of the business
Enterprise
tax any discussion on
that representative PL again any any uh
recommendation or non- reccommendation
it does not bind a future
legislature I would leave it to a future
legislature take it to take a fresh look
at revenues and then decide whether tax
cuts or tax increases or should be on
the table or not but this legislature
should just let the future legislature
worry about it so I that's why I'm
recommending not not recommending not
recommending all of these
bills including this one okay so uh
basically all bills I don't need
recognize you now cuz I know what you're
going to
say is that true I've been gone a couple
of weeks you still know who I am you're
recognizing
me okay thank you thank you uh rep
representative elme yes on I realize
that this is kind of a
charade since it doesn't obligate any
future legislature it gives some kind of
indication however about what we're
thinking
about so I would like to to vote on
these rather than just say none of it
matters which it does really we we will
be voting I think uh to representative
pl's point he's just saying they should
all be not recommended is that correct
that is correct it it's in the future
legislature will decide what's important
and what's not okay thank you yes
representative fellas I would just like
to to speak to that concept of let the
next term decide what they want to do um
saying that we don't recommend it is not
saying we leave it up to you because our
two two choices are to
recommend that it do be that it becomes
or or there should be
legislation on this topic next year or
there should not be legislation on this
topic next year and the only way that we
would be saying we leave it up to you is
if we come out with a
tie in in this committee and in which
case we're going to make the the case
for recommending it or not recommending
it so we that's not really an option
leave it up to
them to your point if it's so that's one
thing I didn't mention for those who are
unsure if a vote ends up in a tie it
will come out without recommendation so
there's really three cases right
recommended not recommended and um
without
recommendation represent
Aly yes I don't think we can talk about
leave it up to then because the law
requires
that they can make up their own minds no
matter what we
do right I mean to yeah I mean I think
on on if there's ones that we feel
passionate about that that we feel like
we wish they passed or some form of them
passed then saying we recommend it for
future legislation does indicate um the
thought of the committee so um so I
think to representative pl's Point yes
nothing the future legislature is not
bound to anything they don't have to
take any of these recommendations but we
as a as a committee still can make our
thoughts known for future legislators
um okay anybody else on HB uh
15 okay close the work session on
hp15 and I will open the work session on
HP 100 which is to repeal the interest
and dividends tax and
um I'm sure everyone knows this is
already passed and been signed by the
governor um so uh in my mind this is
probably not recommended because it's
already passed um so if there's anyone
else who feels differently uh
please indicate they want to
speak okay seeing none I will close the
um the work session on
hp100 I'll open the work session HP 133
relative to repealing the communication
Services
tax and look for any any thoughts on
that representative PL I know where you
stand M no
sitting I should say I know how you're
thinking uh yes representative duet yeah
I think I think we heard a lot of
testimony and it it's something that
that uh not withstanding the argument
that was just made at the beginning of
this something that deserves to be
explored you know with with what we
heard uh in committee so i' I'd want to
see some future uh legislation relative
to Communications tax okay thank you
representative
elme yes I think it's probably the least
defensible tax at this point however um
we
have on repealed an enormous amount of
the revenue of the state the base
revenue of the state and since since
2016 and I would vote against any
attempt to repeal more until we deal
with
that okay seeing no other comments I
will close the work session on HP
133 now open the work session on hp1
1422 relative to the rates of the
business profits tax business Enterprise
tax Communications Services tax and
rooms and meals tax representative
ducet yeah and in the spirit of uh
rapidity here I think these are a bunch
of stuff that was put together um and we
see this come across you pretty much
every banum I think uh we do not
recommend this for further legislation
that these components can be broken down
into individual legislation and
addressed as it should be
individually thank
you uh representative
Southworth uh yes I agree and we did
discuss the possible um needs of the uh
education lawsuit which may be coming
our way but I'd also like to bring up U
my concern which is the needs um for the
child assault
lawsuits um I've read a variety of
Articles it just seems to be getting
bigger and bigger uh what these amounts
are going to be so I just think we have
to proceed with caution for our
committee's uh side of things because I
saw one thing that said 75 million a
year for 10 years and all these
different things are being put out um
that's going to be quite a burden on the
state which I think it's going to be
hard to
avoid thank
you any other
comments okay seeing none we I will
close the work session on HB
1420 uh
1422 now open the work session HP
1492 and um yes representative du
Set uh again I I think this has already
been addressed with a piece of
legislation uh so we have no need
to proceed with
this represent Aly I figured you might
have a comment yes
on on relative to my previous comment
that we've already cost us a great deal
of money and represent of southworth's
reminded to us of the on sonunu center
problems
um getting rid of this particular tax is
um both unconstitutional as far as I'm
concerned because it's the
only burden put on people people who are
wealthy and are not running
businesses in this state and so they are
not paying state
tax um and um the other one is that we
really are going to need as much money
as we can find and this one is the
quickest turn around I well it may not
be we'll
see but I think we're going to have to
turn taxes around next
year representative
duet again uh I'll stick with my
previous comment it it's excuse me can't
I'm
sorry I've never had that problem
before um in effect this this uh income
tax has been phased out and you know the
argument could be made on both sides
relative to the necessity of this tax
but I'm a firm believer that New
Hampshire has no income tax and this was
the elimination of the final component
of an income tax no matter who that
person is a retired person living on the
the uh dividends from their hard work or
anybody anybody else so I would not be
in favor of recommending we have
legislation that addresses this and it
is a moot point to me
uh yes representative spilburg if I may
ask representative Aly I'm not sure I
caught what you were saying did you
indicate you think there's a
constitutional problem with having
repealed interest in dividends we have
in our constitution in the Bill of
Rights section that every
citizen should share the burden of
uh the government that supports
them and that's a modern interpretation
of that wording um and the people
who especially the ones who move into
this state because we don't have an
income tax um think on our not having to
pay towards state taxes
it maybe a ensy little bit for
communication Services tax and when they
go out to
dinner um but everybody else has to pay
that too so it's obviously not an equal
burden in any sense and the
other um part is yes you have repealed
it as an income
tax but you have
not uh
it it was on our books and being paid
for a hundred
years so
um people are used to
it on the way this bill would change
things is to Triple exemptions so that
uh we would get back to a place where
the people who would be paying it would
be the people that couldn't afford to
pay it
uh wouldn't the I don't know if I had
that right but anyway um that the ones
who can't afford to pay it wouldn't be
paying it which is also in line with our
constitutional
principles um and
um on I believe that it is one of the
easiest ways administratively aside from
putting up
rates uh
to start
retrieving the money that we have lost
that caused
reductions in uh in the services going
to municipalities who then have to turn
around and increase their property taxes
so Mr chair brief reply yes yeah um
thank you I didn't hear anything there
would constitute a constitutional
problem um I can't imagine that the
repeal or the failure to tax something
is a constitutional problem so I I agree
with uh representative ducet that In The
Same Spirit uh with HP 100 the
legislator thrashed this through pretty
thoroughly and we don't need to do it
again next term I would hope
okay any other points on this okay
seeing none we'll close the work session
on hp1
1492 uh that concludes all the work
session
work um before we open the exec session
I would like to take a 10-minute break
and keep it to 10 minutes um so that
both sides can caucus if they would like
um the Republicans will stay in this
room um and uh I would ask the um
uh members who are in attendance um out
in the gallery there to um please leave
the room for about 10 minutes we'll
we'll convene back at uh 10:45 thank
you
e
e e
okay good we're right on time
time being 10:46 recess is over and we
will
now go into exact session and we'll
start I'll open the exact session on
hb5 relative to the rate of business
Enterprise tax and recognize
representative duet uh thank you Mr
chairman I would move that uh the
committee recommends for future
legislation hb5
FN do I have a second on that second
second by representative ery and would
you like to speak to your
motion certainly thank you Mr chairman
and if I could um just put this on hold
I'm getting a
alarm if I don't respond to it uh the
police will go let me
just or do you want I'll I'll speak to
it while you're taking care of that Mr
chairman
um as we discussed in work session whe
whether
it's uh reducing or increasing a
business Enterprise tax it's discussion
that should be made and probably will be
made and it's a a simple
uh simple acknowledgement that we move
forward on exploring those
options and do we have a second on that
okay sheet for summary sheet so I'm just
putting up on this
sheet
motion we on a summary sheet you know
you put who SEC who motion who seconded
motion no not Jordan
seconded I got
it all right should we ask
Karen different than normal session we
just recommend a Rec no it's still we
would still fill out yeah do you want to
check with Karen see if um any
discussion on this represent
Aly yes um I'm opposed
to considering next term considering the
financial situation we're likely to be
in um on making any attempt to further
reduce our tax our tax
revenue any other comments
yes
represent As I understood representative
duet's U motion this was relative to the
rate I didn't say whether it was going
to be increased or decreased thank
you interesting
point uh yes
representative thank you Mr chair uh at
the risk of uh being the one who points
out or having been told I have a keen
grasp of the obvious it's important to
recognize that not making a decision is
making a decision it means that we are
deciding to keep the current status so
um let's be clear that not making a
decision to make something different
means that we are making a decision to
keep what we have thank
you thank you represent
Aly yes I would just like to point out
that the bill itself
clearly uh speaks to reducing the rate
of the business Enterprise
tax okay
um if there's uh nothing else I'm going
to close the exact session on
hp15 and I'll ask the clerk to call the
role as as soon as we give him a chance
to fill out the
sheet you use it as
AET how many columns do
you that's probably why he made to
yeah 6
seven I think
okay do you have and you have all the
corrected names I do okay all
right um starting with representative
duet yes clearly State the it's uh oh
yeah the motion uh I don't know if we
stated the motion the motion is um to
recommend future legislation hb15
F yes uh representative DEET yes uh
representative erery yes representative
G
gagy yes representative spillsbury yes
representative plfs yes representative
sodi yes representative Oris yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Aly no okay I went out of order I I'll
ask in a second represent
bogur yes
okay uh representative Aly no
representative Ames no representative
Southworth no represent Malloy no
Representative shamberg no
representative fellows no representative
Bolton no represent elberger no
representative haaken Phillips
no uh who's substituting for
Smith huh oh oh I'm sorry yeah you are
here I sorry representative
Smith yes I'm sorry no okay uh and the
chair yes the vote is 10 10
shocking okay this uh the vote being
1010 this will go um on the record is
without
recommendation I I have a question
what's that when it Tes it goes as the
committee was
UN you said that
earlier which is without recomendation
uh let me pull out U some a document
that Paul uh the clerk Paul Smith has
sent um he said that
um oh without without recomend without
recommendation on on the
bill well on so we're not rec
recomending it for future legislation
and we are not not recommending and not
not recommending right so it's uh it's
without recommendation yeah
so yes so is it do we treat it like a
regular Bill
and and put down both opinions or not
thank you for asking that no um the on
for the purposes of all these whether
it's with recommendation without
recommendation um or not recommended
there's only one
um statement so when it's without when
it goes without recommendation the chair
just writes a a very
short um sentence basically that it's
without recommendation um and then if so
if the majority votes one way or the
other there'll be a report for whatever
that majority opinion is and that's it
there's no minority reports there's no
yeah
any other questions yeah yes represent
Ames I just I had come across a uh a
calendar entry from house record from uh
2022 in November where this situation
arose and um the statement was without
recommendation and then the blurb was
the committee was unable to reach a
consensus of whether to recommend
further legislation or not
right right that's what we would be
doing it's
um yeah so actually actually from the
actually for the clerk I have a sentence
here the the committee was unable to
reach a consensus of whether to
recommend further legislation or not
similar to what you just said there you
go that's it so okay thank you um okay
so that's um I'll close the exact
session on hb15 my only comment is that
wording is the or not is superfluous
okay um I'm now going to open the um
exec session for
HP uh and recognized representative
ducet thank you Mr chair I uh I move the
committee votes
to not
[Music]
recommend yeah future legislation on HB
100 FN as it's already been addressed in
legislation do I have a
second
second are you seconding it oh let's uh
representative Aly seconds
it
okay uh the uh any discussion would you
like to no you just said
okay seeing no further discussion uh the
clerk will call the role mark previous
one hold
on okay um the motion uh
on FNA is to not recommend
representative duet yes representative
uh
erery uh yes representative gagy yes
represent spillsbury yes represent PL
votes yes representative sodi yes
represent ORS yes represent uh Melvin
yes representative
bogert
Aly yes represent of Ames yes repres
Southworth
yes represent Malloy yes representative
shambre yes representative fellos yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative hien
Phillips yes is it hacking or haaken
it's hacking like a computer hack okay
sorry thanks for from my mistakes so far
forgive me uh representative Smith yes
and the chair
yes so the recommended is TW the vote is
20 to not
recommend okay um vote being 20 to zero
this will go as not recommend and I will
close the exec session on HP
100 next up I'll open the exec session
on HB 133 and recognize representative
ducet thank you Mr chairman I would
recommend the
committee uh recommend to the committee
a motion of uh Rec recommend future
legislation on HB 133
FN do I have a second
who second representative
sod and would you like to speak to your
motion representative who said yeah very
briefly uh argument has been made and
we've heard testimony on both sides of
this
uh really my voice is that bad today I
apologize I
apologize we've we've heard testimony on
both sides uh of this issue and I think
it warrants further legislative uh
action okay other
comments yes Mr chair oh yes I see the
microphone yes
represent wasn't this tax instituted as
a rich person's tax in about
services on communication yeah
Communications Services tax
but I'm not familiar with that history
but it's
more
okay okay seeing uh no other comments uh
I'll close the exact uh no I'm not going
to close the exact I'll ask the clerk to
call the role thank you Mr chair uh the
motion on HB 1333 FN is to recommend
start with represent new set yes
represent spills
excuse me representative
erery
yes uh representative SP
gagy yes representative spillsbury yes
representative
PL votes votes yes representative sodi
yes representative ORS yes
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes represent Aly no
representative
Ames no representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no Representative
shamberg no representative fellows no
representative Bolton no Representative
elberger no representative hicken Phil
hacken Phillips no representative Smith
no the
chair yes the vote is 1010
shocking okay I will close the exec
session on HB 13 3
FN now open the exec session for hp1
1422 FNA a
local and recognize representative ducet
thank you Mr chairman I would
recommend uh no uh future legislation on
hb1
1422 um that and not recommend not
recommend do I have a second
represent Al represent Al me seconds it
okay let me catch up yeah and as we
discussed in work session this is
uh too many components it should be
broken down into its individual
components
uh and we will'll pursue those
legislatively as those individual
components in my
opinion thank you anybody
else seeing none I'll ask clerk to call
the rooll when he's
ready all right uh this the motion on
hp1 1422 FNA local is to not recommend
starting with representative duet yes
represent spillsbury excuse me
representative uh
erery yes representative Gagney yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative plv yes representative
sodi yes representative ORS yes
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative Aly
yes representative Ames yes represent
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
represent shamberg yes represent fellos
yes representative Bolton yes represent
elberger yes uh sorry
okay that was uh represent elberger
voted yes uh representative hacken
Phillips yes representative Smith yes
and the chair yes roote is
20 to not
recommend I'll now close the exec
session on hp1 1422
next up uh opening exec session on hb1
1492 and recognize representative
ducet thank you Mr chairman I would move
uh no future legislation on hb1 1492 as
it's that's my motion yeah do I have a
second second represent second it
representa would you like to speak as as
spoken about earlier it's been addressed
in legislation
already any
comments represent Aly given that there
will be future legislation I would like
to see recommended for future
legislation but the the vote the motion
on the floor is not recommend people can
vote for it or against it as they so
choose okay so uh was there a second
let's see the second was by YY
okay any other
comments okay saying none I'm sorry I
just lose this is 569 no no 1492
right
e for
hey I'm
ready okay the clerk will call the
Rong okay the uh the motion of 1492 is
to not recommend they start with
representative duet yes representative
spillsbury
and representative erery
yes representative gagy yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL M oh
yes representative sodi yes represent
ores yes representative Melvin
yes representative uh bogur yes
represent Aly
no represent Ames no represent
Southworth no represent Malloy no
Representative shanberg no
Representative fellos no representative
Bolton no Representative elberger no
representative hacken Phillips no uh
representative Smith no the chair yes
the vote is 1010 a big
one okay the vote being 1010 this will
also go without
recommendation um and I'll close the
exec session on 1492
uh but I no I don't I just red the wrong
sheet and C huh
up
set okay I'm going to open the exact
session on HB 569 FN and recognize
representative spillsbury for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move uh that we
recommend HP 569 for future legislation
do I have a second from representative
Ames okay representative Ames seconds it
got it
would you like to speak to your motion
representative spillsbury yes um so I
think that uh as our work session
indicated we have three good alternative
Avenues to addressing swept we should
encourage that all three of these ideas
be preserved and brought forward again
next uh term so uh In The Same Spirit as
we take up 514 and 15 1514 and
1563 um I would hope we would vote um
recommend similarly to all three of them
and we can then uh wait and see and
frankly if the court hasn't decided by
the time we're going through these in
the winter uh we can
retain thank you any other
comments representative
Ames yes I I would just uh like
to um agree basically agree with what
representative spillsbury has has just
said and and note perhaps it's important
to note that this is a very significant
subject matter that's being addressed by
these bills and we uh will all need to
uh roll up our sleeves and uh work to
find the best possible solution as we go
forward but it definitely needs uh
future
legislation thank you thank
you okay seeing uh no more comments I'll
ask the clerk to call the role yes and
you see me hesitating I have to bounce
up and down on this sheet to get it
right so it's it's confusing sometimes
uh uh fourth person down on this sheet
represent duet how do you vote for this
is to not to recommend HB
569 yes representative erery yes
representative gagy yes representative
spillsbury yes representative plvs yes
representative sodi yes representative
ORS yes representative Melvin yes
representative
bogur yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes represent of
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative fellow yes representative
Bolton yes representative elberger yes
representative hacken Phillips yes
representative Smith yes the chair yes
the vote is 20 to
recommend okay the vote being 20 to Z we
will go forward with the
recommendation and I'll close the EXA
session on HB
569 next up we'll open the exec session
on HB
1514 FNA
local and look and uh representative
spillsbury would you like to make a
motion yes thank you Mr chair I move
that we recommend future legislation
along the lines of
hb514 and ask for your support do I have
a
second representative
Ames and would you like to speak to your
motion all set thank you any other
comments okay seeing none the clerk will
call the
role okay this is a motion to
recommend on HBO
hb514 FNA local representative duet how
do you V yes representative spillsbury
excuse me representative erery yes
represent gagy yes represent spillsbury
yes represent PL votes yes
representative sodi yes represent ORS
yes representative Melvin yes
representative bogert yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
represent Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes represent shamber yes
representative fellow yes representative
Bolton yes represent elberger yes
represent hacken Phillips yes represent
Smith yes and the chair yes the vote is
20 to zero to
recommend okay the vote being 20 to
zero HP 1514 will go recommended for
future legislation and I'll close the
exact session on it
last upep is uh I'll open the exec
session on HB 1563 FN and representative
spillsbury would you like to make a
motion thank you I move that we
recommend future legislation along the
lines of hb1
1563 do I have a second second my second
represent fellow seconds
any
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the role as soon as he's
ready and his his wrist is getting a
good
workout
yes too bad nobody can read anything I
write okay uh this is 1563 FN the motion
is to recommend starting with
representative duet yes representative
erery
H sure represent gagy yes represent
spillsbury yes represent PL votes yes
represent sodi yes represent foris yes
representative Melvin yes representative
ogert yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes represent
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
represent shamberg yes represent fellow
yes represent Bolton
yes represent alberger yes repres hacken
Phillips yes represent Smith yes and the
chair yes the vote is 20 to Zer to
recommend okay the vote being 20 to Z
this uh hb1
1563 will go with recommendation for
future legislation and I'll close the
exec session on
it okay that concludes our exec session
now I want everyone to note that there
there is one other bill hb14
29 that uh when I had done a search
about a month ago to see what interim
study bills were left that did not come
up um
and but hb14 so in theory we would need
a a meeting on that but um I've talked
to the clerk um there was a Senate bill
that pass it was it was a bill dealing
with dams the Senate bill was very
similar that's why we put it in interim
study to see how the Senate bill would
work out Senate bill passed um and the
house passed that version of it so there
really uh in my mind no need to come
back for a another meeting to address
this um if we don't come back and meet
about it it'll go on as without
recommendation but given that it's
already passed in its Senate form I
don't see any need to do that is there
anyone that
firmly and um disagrees with that and
and wants to come back and talk about
this or we all good that this will go
without recommendation
I see a thumbs up okay good um I kind of
figured that's the way it might go all
right thank you thank you all we I will
tell the clerk that we're going to go
without recommendation for that um and
uh yes representative PL Mr chair I
chose not to run again uh and so this is
my last session with Ways and Means or
any other committee for that matter I
just want to say the last few two years
has been extremely enjoyable I learned a
lot and I appreciated the mostly
nonpartisan approach of ways and means
and uh I'll miss it but uh I chose not
to run due to age and health conditions
and I I've been swamped beyond belief so
I have to slow down somewhere thank you
thank you uh representative pl we really
appreciate it and I think we'll give you
a round of
applause is there anyone else on the
committee that uh did not run um or
um yes I ran but um I'm wondering who a
representative PL might reign as the
next uh dadjoke
person it's your
choice all right well uh thank you
everyone this uh concludes our last
meeting of uh this terms ways and means
and I appreciate um all your work and
effort thank
you for